الاداه المجانيه التي يمكنها كتابه
المقالات والقصائد وحتى التخطيط للاجازات
بالطريقه ذاتها التي يفعلها الانسان طبعا
خلقت سؤال كبير حول الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل
عام هل يضر بالبشريه اكثر مما ينفعها
سمويل وهو رئيس شركه اوبن اي للذكاء
الاصطناعي والتي صنعت
شات جي بي تي قال خلال افادته امام
الكونغرس الامريكيه ان فوائد هذا التطبيق
الجديد تفوق المخاطر حتى الان محذرا من
تغير الحال اذا لم تتم مراقبته في حين
يلعب الذكاء الاصطناعي دورا كبيرا في
تطوير بعض المجالات كالطب مكافحه ايضا
ازمات المناخ من شدده على اهميه تشكيل
وكاله امريكيه او ربما عالميه ترخص انظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي على ان تتمتع بسلطه سحب
هذا الترخيص وضمان الامتثال لم السلامه
راى التمن انه على هذه الوكاله التنظيميه
الجديده فرض ضمنت لتنظيم عمل نماذج الذكاء
الاصطناعي التي يمكنها التكرار والتسلل
الذاتي في اشاره طبعا ربما الى اسوا
المخاوف المستقبليه تجاه تلك الانظمه
المتقدمه والتي يمكن ان تتابع بالبشر
وايضا تسيطر عليهم بمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات